معركه بخموت مستمره منذ سبعه اشهر هي اطول
معارك حرب اوكرانيا واكثرها دمويه حقق
الروس تقدما كبيرا وحاصروا المدينه من عده
جهات لكن الاوكرانيين مصرون على الدفاع عن
المدينه يؤكد اغلب الخبراء العسكريين ان
بخمد لا تشكلوا اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره
ولن يغير مصيرها مجال الحرب لكن الرئيس
الاوكراني قال ان سقوطها سيمكن الروس من
الذهاب ابعد ليصلوا الى اكراماتورسك
وسوفيانسك وان الطريق سيكون مفتوحا امامهم
لما حزيران الى امكانيه الانسحاب من بخمه
لكن قواته تدافع عنها بالسماته فلماذا كل
هذا الاصرار على الدفاع عن ضخمه بالنسبه
الى الاوكرانيين تكتسبه اهميه على
المستويين الرمز والعسكري على المستوى
الرمزي تحولت باخموت الى رمز للمقاومه
الاوكرانيه بعدما كانت ماريو بول هي الرمز
خلال مرحله من الحرب قبل سقوطها بيد الروس
اما على المستوى العسكري فان معركه تمكن
من انهاك القوات الروسيه المقاتله هناك
وتحديدا اذ تقول وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان سبعه جنود الروس يسقطون مقابل كل جندي
اوكراني لا يمكن التاكد من هذا الرقم لكن
المعروفه ان القوات المهاجمه تدفع ثمنا
اكبر من القوات التي تدافع عن مكان تحت
سيطرتها ويبدو ان هناك هدفا اخر عبرت عنه
وسائل اعلام قريبه من الجيش الاوكراني
التي تحدثت عن ان الصمود في هدفه ان يبدا
الروس في ضرب بعضهم هنا اشاره الى
الخلافات بين قوات فاغنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه فقد انتقد قائد فاغنر
عده مرات وزاره الدفاع وقياده اركان الجيش
وقال انه لا يحصل على الذخيره وان هناك
عرقله لتحرك قواته الذي استعد للاحتفال
باسقاط مع ما يعنيه ذلك من توسيع للنفوذ
في موسكو بدا يشتك